[Music]
in global crisis news oh no I know what
it is submitted by edges sketch it's not
the MCU thing is it we talked about
spider-man now do anything do anything
decent on an etch-a-sketch I couldn't
afford one I did my name was guys I did
a car on vacant day care the car okay
yeah I don't think anyone was ever good
at discussions um the Amazon rainforest
is on fire and burning at a record rate
oh no what does this have to do with me
the air that you breathe yeah it's 20%
of the world's oxygen that's produced
it's the world's long no I don't know if
it weight 80% of the oxygens like chill
spider-man now that's funny this has
been happening for like three years
wait the whole place under there for
three years they've been sectioning it
off they're burly you just kind of movie
I'll be burning it on purpose
I saw a picture I saw a picture though
of how much burning is going on and that
shit's like bigger than some countries
you can see it from space I heard yeah
but you can also see them my rage from
space and what Sony did do no one knows
what you're talking about
I'm talking about what they say the true
fans know I don't know sure the to
spider-man fans know exactly what he's
talking about
thank you no it was algae produces the
most oxygen for people oh [ __ ] the algae
in the ocean yeah it's like the super
tiny microscopic things I forgot the
name of it phytoplankton no I don't
think they produce oxygen but they're
saying that I learned it on one strange
rock it's really good show effects and
you didn't learn it because you're not
trained to be proper with my words I
heard about it okay so the tweet that
went viral recently was this one it says
I can't sleep because yeah your nods
can't sleep it cocked up sorry I can't
sleep because the amazon has been
burning for three weeks and I'm just now
finding out because of the lack of media
coverage this is
one of the most important ecosystems on
earth spread awareness pray for Amazonia
let's save it retweet to spread the
information I don't know they're saying
that no one's talking about it because
literally unlike every news channel
African African names sound Japanese huh
on daddy yeah Bhutto what are you
talking about that sounds like an
African name is he Emma's on video yeah
Bhutto but so the photos here that are
included in this tweet a lot of people
are saying that these are really old
photos and like one of them is like from
the 90s and the other ones from like
2001 or something I have a question if
the Amazon is so wet how does it burn so
that's where it's all hoax bark see well
they're saying that people were coming
with kerosene and actually dumping and
starting fires for kell okay
so I thought geckos are not flammable
matters are too wet to be very wet
lizards bunnies are though come on the
rain forest fires it used to be
considered a once in a century kind of
thing but now there's so many so
frequently because it's mainly man-made
and because of climate change so now the
rain forest isn't as wet as it used to
be so now and make it wet or they hose
it down and the dry season by man-made
is it's like an accident or their
purpose but every summer though there's
there are natural fires that occur in
the Amazon as well all over the world
yeah where there's a for whatever that's
I'm saying the dry season it's normal
like yes it happens but the way that
it's happening now at the rate yeah at
the rate it's the southern hemisphere
they're in the sub B in this winter
right now right that says that this year
has seen more than double the number of
fires in Brazil than in 2013 so yeah
every year there's fires happening and a
lot of them are man-made because they're
trying to make room for their crops like
it's it's farmers are doing the 2016
gets second place Ville but they're
doing it illegally
that's horrible yeah and they're legally
why illegally because they're burning
the amazon has made these for their
forests all four farms owe money off it
and that's why the government doesn't
give a [ __ ] because they're making more
money
and so the president's that we've talked
about recently how he was saying
everyone should poop once a week or some
[ __ ] does the other nice ass I don't
know look at his face I doubt it people
from Brazil have nice asses right it
wasn't Leo DiCaprio if he just got
really drugged up and old and old yeah
so Leonardo DiCaprio even at 80 will
never look like that yeah he's just got
the Yammer Leonardo DiCaprio but like a
warm jar of mayonnaise I think it's just
the shape of his head yeah they're
trying to make way for cattle pasture um
they're burning forests for that or like
just planning [ __ ] or whatever yeah so
they're trying to make room for the
farming and stuff and so they so right
now they're saying that since this
president has gone into office in
January there have been an insane amount
like he pretty much lessened a lot of
the policies that will protect the
rainforest and the ecosystem and a lot
of stuff like you lessened these
policies so now there's more things I
used to be legal now they're legal that
they can get away with but it's [ __ ]
up the climate and the ecosystem there
so that's why now there's more media
attention because that tweet went viral
and a lot of celebrities started
tweeting about it but then that's when
people are saying like well there are a
lot of fires this isn't like one time
and crazy thing well it still something
to be concerned about but this was a
massive wondering and also if like this
is his backyard why does the world care
only 20% though it's only 20% so it
looks like our oceans are getting [ __ ]
up even more - so everything's all
higher I did read what the consequences
are of a 20% decrease in oxygen and just
like [ __ ] heating up and how it could
[ __ ] [ __ ] up but I don't know how long
it's gonna take for it to take an effect
but I guess like if that maintains every
year what happens like it increases the
global warming or whatever yeah because
I don't kow burps increase global
warming top arts
and then we have a [ __ ] ton of cows and
just eat them all [ __ ] vegans yeah yeah
so think so if it's for cattle ranching
there's more cattle doing that and all
right yeah yeah but vegans like to say
that there wouldn't be as many cows if
not for mediators people that's what
they say
well I'm trying to help you get rid of
the cows for global warming so they
don't want the man if they don't want me
to eat it and we get more global warming
that's their [ __ ] less supply okay
but yeah I don't know like even though
it's in his backyard it does affect the
entire planet in the way the entire
world's ecosystems yeah but that's why
I'm equating that to our cattle farming
because I they have that but we need to
be responsible to we have a [ __ ] ton of
cow farts coming from us so and I wonder
how we would perceive it if other
countries started going into our
backyard and go hey stop being so much
beef my god I would be like oh [ __ ] this
is some [ __ ] we gotta really think about
that's true why don't other countries
put us on check because it feels like
America and Western countries love to go
into other countries and keep policing
them to everybody yeah yeah but that's
because we're literally in every country
just about that's not dope we all right
I mean no we're dead that's that's how
pervasive our [ __ ] like the CIA is
every [ __ ] in every country in Africa
yeah that's true so because I watched
this one documentary about the whaling
industry and then I and in Japan came
out with their own documentary about
opposing that and there's a like there's
a [ __ ] ton of like activists coming into
this Japanese town and and just
harassing the citizens there and calling
them murderers and all that stuff and
it's like why don't they leave them
alone and it's because of the dolphins
yeah yeah it's like it's it's it's whale
yet at the cove so because of the cove
that documentary it's in it's a really
[ __ ] up misinformed one to the
documentaries yeah yeah because the I
watched the opposing one and then also
the townspeople there are trying to have
discourse or like a discussion with the
activists and the activists are acting
[ __ ] belligerent and militant and
like they're just being [ __ ]
difficult and
so they're like you've got it all you
got to respect the culture but they
don't even do that they just come in
abrasive and they're like yelling at
these poor fishermen and it's like what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you yeah but I
saw the cove and so I feel like you're
using a lot of anti anti dolphin farming
talking points which is what I say when
somebody has an argument that I don't
agree well they say that it's a talking
point so they don't have to actually
address their argument that interesting
they they want to have a discussion and
they're actually playing to the
activists and the activists don't want
to discuss anything and they all they
want to do is just yell in their faces
and be crazy and then just kind of scare
these kids and people of that town and
I'm like well that's a very Western
thing to do right is go into these
countries and tell them what the [ __ ]
they should be doing that's how I feel
about like when I read people there's a
lot of good reading the Amazon thing too
and even with the Hawaii volcano thing
with the preeminent you know telescope
it just seems like awareness awareness
awareness but they're like well what are
you gonna do about it
nothing changes because of the public
outcry
yeah like good it might get to someone
who actually does something what's under
the microscope of the world we have
they're forced to do something vermin
officials give a [ __ ] about their image
big time so so when when things look bad
and they could look bad because of it
that's what makes up for China China
don't give up oh let's give a [ __ ]
because they censor everything they do
shoot but they just don't want murals
they just have more control over it so
I'm just glad that America doesn't
suffer nobody yeah never I'm glad that
Google would never help them do that
either love Google YouTube has never
censored anyone ever or YouTube so this
other tweet went viral as well I said
this is South follow today 4:00 p.m. the
cloud from the burning of Amazon honest
Amazon rainforest in redonda covered the
city Sao Paulo is 2050 two miles away
distant from Boavista and closer okay so
are you sure that's not the fog machine
from the disco clips are you sure that's
not a talking point
so this is a logging industry talking
point it's an spirit it's propaganda so
there's that scientists are looking into
whether or not the forest burning is
causing this cloud or it's just a foggy
day it's gonna be a thousand miles away
like that must be a [ __ ] ton of trees
burning crazy I mean there's like the
burn area looks like a whole country
yeah because when Hawaii has vogue you
know like the volcanic fog or whatever
yeah it covers it like a cloud - how big
is the Amazon - it's like 300 square
that's just like half a mark a minute
they said that they said that it's got a
lot of countries dude it's this country
people are probably gonna want to kill
me two point one two four million mile
square miles I was very close you know
what I'm 300 square feet parts like it's
like as big as Central Park I think I'm
hoping that they finally find the the
lost city treasure the ancient city the
Golden City you're talking about
Eldorado
yeah Eldorado down oh you speak some
good Spanish I felt ministry time I'm
hoping that like in the middle of all
this like Eldorado comes out and then
all the gold is there and then all the
farmers don't have to burn this for us
anymore because they get the gold and
then they kill all the farmers so they
can get the gold yeah
now let me see
[Music]